what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation once again joined by Tara Erickson how are
you I hate you I'm good here's my Goosebumps
t-shirt what are we watching today ghost
Rider similar to our Fantastic Four experience I
had only seen this one one time 2007 needless to
say I only remember one scene and I'll get it
out of the way right now it's Nicholas Cage's
Marvel body shot and that's only because
my friend's girlfriend made a really funny
comment when it happened other than that I
can't tell you what happens in this movie
so I'm excited to re-watch for the first time
but this is Tara's first time watching this
neither of us have seen the sequel so if this
goes well we'll watch spirit of Vengeance and
we'll see how chaotic that experience is are
you excited Tara I'm excited there's a guy on
fire on the poster do you know anything about
Ghost Rider no nothing that's exciting ladies
and gentlemen leave a like leave a like and uh
special to do that if you want to watch spirit
of Vengeance and if you want to make sure
you get notified for a spirit of entrance
ring that Bell I wonder what the retention is
of how many people actually subscribe because
you did full length Reaction watch song where
you single with your own copy of Ghost Rider
available for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who have joined
because we've covered so many movies and
some stuff over there as well awful and you
know what I have to say the same stuff all the
time just to say thank you got exclusive stuff
over there we covered reaction all right
let's watch songs Google let's get to it
Oh that's oh sweet oh all right Marvel get it
tall tales that help us make sense of things
too great we're too terrifying to believe sounds
like Santa's voiceover is the best it has to be
Sam Elliott right yeah it sounds like him some
damn Soul cursed to ride the Earth collecting
on the devil's deals the devil is in Mephisto
a ghost rider was sent to the Village of San
venganza but that contract was so powerful he knew
he could never let the devil get his hands on it
whoa the Outland the devil he
ghosted the devil yeah man the
devil deserved it the thing about
Legends is sometimes they're true
I'm just gonna say I already love everything this
is fun it's like a Gothic horror action movie
yeah oh my God I need a Ghostwriter t-shirt
and I haven't even watched the movie yet
oh my God he's like Johnny Storm
it looks like Chris Evans yeah
hot shot angel boy and you do things
without thinking you ain't making the
choice the choice is making you I was just
doing it for the crowd both know why you've
done it there are themes here she's going
to stand by you when you're in a wheelchair
I mean it just ran over a rock right hey that one
rock could have led to a concussion yeah right man
what's wrong Roxy I'm leaving my dad's sending
me to live with my mom this is where you kill her
we'll jump on the back and just
keep going but what about your dad
show he doesn't need tomorrow noon we'll meet here
oh young love so sweet bound to end
God he actually loves him but I bet you he's
never hugged him that would be too gay Tara
he's dying
oh
sweet oh my goodness all right worried about
your father about cancer is the time it takes
Nate do you see that oh yeah what if I could
make him better give me a price I'll take
your soul yeah by sunrise tomorrow your father
will be healthy as a horse all you have to do
is inside when the dad eventually die just
from old age yeah but he wasn't that old
ah well that'll do just fine morning sleeping
beauty healthy as a horse you look great right
I've been sick son I'm not anymore I can't
explain it but I feel healthy as a horse
that's exactly what the devil said
girlfriend's gonna have to wait
all right
uh what
oh my God so the devil was like I'm
gonna make him well but you I didn't
say he'd be around for like more
than a day what a meanie dead dead
okay
so the person he makes the deal whoa
the person makes a deal with is also the villain
that's interesting one day when I need you
I will come I'll be watching oh
she doesn't even know about his dad
is he just gonna keep riding oh my gosh
you're not gonna at least ride up there
and be like yo my dad died and also I made a
deal with the devil but like literally what
uh okay you can't live in fear you can't live
in fear it's a southern rat Nicholas Cage
like how
oh like the devil gets him across okay
whoa oh my God that was so painful oh my
gosh holy junk damn the real stunt man do that
[__] that looks so painful whoa that had to
be like CGI right because that looked insane
heck is it back okay but it's fine thank you
oh my God call it Mr Invincible
it'll have to be At a next jump
Johnny Blaze will attempt to clear for the length
of a football field from field goal to field goal
field goal to field goal no way
possible there's no way he'll die
you should be taking a dirt nap after that
Ragdoll day I got lucky luck don't cover it JB
and you got an angel looking after you yeah
maybe a dark angel maybe it's something else
AKA Satan hell yeah
you wear him Venom shirt
oh my God hell's freezing over I think you might
be lost boy you got a problem
with that as a matter of fact
everybody
Wicked all right cool Wes Bentley that's that
actor's name it took me a while can I
just turn this music off for a minute
Mac you touch the Carpenters or that chimp
video again we got a scrap on our hands
at least promise me you'll think about taking
the cars out I'll think about it man oh cool
what is the purpose of why you're doing this
just for fun hello Russell what why are you here
another like Elemental villains I've
come for the contract of Santa ganza
and when we find it then what then we'll
take this world what about Mephistopheles
there's some cool designs
but Johnny Blaze don't do no interviews okay
not even for an old friend who this girl okay
whoever Mendes that's right from
high school I forgot that was her
what's going through your mind right
now you look really good Johnny what
drives somebody to risk their life for
entertainment I heard you got married
most of the time the Press focuses on the crashes
the cost of what you do there any other costs uh
yeah oh my God so Nicholas Cage
I'm gonna stay for the job bro
you know we gotta get back plus
I never liked watching you jump
ouch what did he ever do to you he just
loved her thank God you listen to me take
the cars out would have been otherwise will not be
jumping 50 cars but instead we'll be leaving six
why JB why helicopters man instead
of the cars or the ring of fire I
helicopter my dad thought it'd be cool
my dad thought it'd be cool how much
noise did you put in the tanks enough
to change the space shuttle Keith
go ahead let's go all right man
wow off to the interstate
he goes now do it again yeah
I made it pull over
this is really dangerous for that helmet Johnny
still like Italian Italian look you were
17 and you witnessed a tragedy and you
ran I have no hard feelings none you know and
that's why they call it the past because it's
past it's done it's over with wow all right
there's a restaurant in my hotel the Plaza
eight o'clock yes oh my gosh Nicholas Cage
oh my gosh yes
oh my goodness Mephistopheles I knew
you'd come long time no see boys a
Memphis stoplight so it is Mephisto okay it's
my contract we both know you can't harm me here
you will suffer for this you guys
are hurting each other's Optics I
will retire him just like I will retire
you father ah it's a lot of visuals all
right for five lines of dialogue a lot
of lights on lights off type of situation
oh my God is he gonna stand her up
that would be hilarious you made that
job no one else made that job you're the
best writer you deserve a second chance
she's a sign come on man like how long
is this pep talk been is he on fire now
this is so cringy come on man
terrible why aren't you there
Johnny can you imagine standing
her up I know I wouldn't ever
sweet I barely know how to ride a bicycle
Hello Johnny stay away from me
you're like a semi Elvis thing
I'm the one known as Blackheart I'm
not doing it you don't have any choice
oh Wicked wow the true meaning of burning rubber
holy [__] oh my goodness
foreign
political messaging happen here what happened
to the graves they moved them Michael's Church
whoa
oh let's see it
that's cool
all right you're going down I don't think so
what
oh Jesus I mean you can't really
kill a ghost you ain't so tough
have mercy sorry all out in Mercy
oh awesome
whoa cool whoa that's pretty
awesome Ash Embers yeah
it's like a like a pet a motorcycle
pet oh my gosh oh wow okay
it's got a skull oh my goodness
oh my God that's great so
aesthetically cool give me the damn bag
I forget her name Rebel Wilson
yeah that it is yeah guilty
die now
oh that's really cool developing him
in the nightmares that he has induced
man you're gonna have to be making a lot of stops
not bad 2007. cool transition
for back in the day oh
Sam Elliott oh is this a cemetery they're looking
for yes the answer to hear other questions last
night did happen and it will happen again you
are the writer the Ghost Rider get used to it
kid it'll be a lot easier how does he know
all this yeah like he's very well informed
writers the devil's Bounty Hunter since
I hunt down anyone that escaped from hell
why does it have to be Johnny Storm though
could it be anyone it seems like it's not
Johnny Storm specific it was um Punk and
I could see all the wrong you never done
turned it all against him the pin and
steer Penance there last one was 150
years ago a little town called San benganza
the straighter came along making promises
consumed by agreed they turned on one another
Sam Ellie makes it so much more believable yeah
thanks for the info I feel much better now
that I know I'm the devil's Bounty Hunter
oh my God that's all from his flames
that's right when he was going through all that
oh yeah it's like a gravitational
pull of stuff his face was a skull
yeah like
let me apologize last night was inexcusable
College I got a great job you're just the same
eyes really that blue I was just wondering that
that has got to be like some CGI blue in there
hey Captain I got something a license plate it's
probably for one of these cars that was destroyed
yeah this is the moment I remember oh dang
holy junk he did get very fit it's like Is
that real cut right that's crazy it
doesn't look real it really doesn't
but his stomach is moving when he
does that like it clenches like it is
all right Nick Cage we see you
give me control over the possessing
oh no whoa I came to apologize
I'm leaving town tonight and uh I didn't want
what I said today to be the last words between us
she's apologizing to him yeah it's insane why
was he just like you don't have to apologize
I remember that day terrified
that my dad was gonna come in
yeah God not enough women are like
her and Jessica Alba from Fantastic
why he can't get attached man he's the Ghost
Rider oh my God you almost kill yourself on
the highway so you can ask me out and then
you don't show then keep my picture but when
I kiss you you try to shove me out the door
what's what's going on tell her you're the
Ghost Rider tell her you can control fire I saw
my soul of the devil I knew I had to spare you
spare me from what the devil on account I work
for him that's why I couldn't make it to dinner
it was Bounty Hunter but it only happens at night
whenever I'm around evil evil people evil spirits
have changed into just show her the fire
in your hand he's a creepy monster but I
am learning to I'm getting control of it this
is your excuse for the past for last night
for everything it's the truth Roxanne yeah man
he's working for the devil just show her the
fire truck she'll believe you I don't know why
he's not doing that I realize that you'd rather
make up ridiculous stories and be honest
with me and I walk out of that door forever
goodbye forever man you should go after
her when you're when you're Ghost Rider
yeah also just light if you just let your
hand on fire it all would have been fine
you're coming with us okay
this guy was three years from retirement
never harmed a flying his life in fact
neither did most of the corpses turning
up since you came home you son of a [__]
provide a very very important
civil service in fact when I
finished my stone career I intend to apply
my skills to being a motorcycle policeman
what do they have on him I don't know because
they found the license plate remember so there's
so much no I know please please you don't want to
put me in there sorry the rich was booked they're
all going to be lit on fire buddy please get me
out of here oh God he can see all their bad stuff
oh man leave him alone
whoa
nice jacket
very nice how do you ensure the
jacket doesn't catch on fire
yeah let the kid out
his sweater said Wicked jester
sweet awesome run kid run oh man all this
first opportunity to get out of there really
dang it whoa
all right
I wonder if Nicholas Cage did mocap for
this he's supposed to be doing good but
everywhere he goes is excessive property
damage he's destroying the city you've
been protecting it all these years it's foreign
a secrecy want to keep it from the likes of you
oh
I really do enjoy the look
of this movie a lot yeah
yeah it's badass
what yeah man what is it gonna like turn into a
boat oh my gosh it can ride underwater shut up
oh my gosh shut up you hear the
middle finger that is awesome
oh [__] oh my goodness oh that's cool anything
you're gonna get blamed for that yep
Johnny
that's not doing good Johnny
you're pissing me off sorry
oh oh You released him oh yeah all right all
you have to do is apologize to the Ghost Rider
you cannot catch the wind
ah
whoa dope I love how they try to hang him
with that chain and that chain
has become his Ultimate Weapon
whoa that was a cool shot
hundreds of people just had glass fall on them
foreign
awesome Legend has it he was a Texas Ranger but
he got greedy Slade made a deal ended up a Ghost
Rider remember that contract The Stranger made
with the people's son to Gonza yes but what he
found there was so evil that he took the contract
black card is coming stay away from friends and
family anybody he can use against it because
he will you should not have walked near her in
her Direction okay well lately he's been reading
these really weird books and he's writing stuff
down and he's staying up late and he he does
it over here you can go through this stuff and
I don't know if it means anything she'll figure
it out she's a journalist yeah she does the news
why are you gasping because that's
what she does in this not even close
I liked it I know he was great that is hot so
now I must take it now I'm gonna break it oh
look into my eyes your pen and
stare doesn't work on me I guess
I guess caretaker forgot to mention
that huh caretakers Sam Elliott
you work for me get the contract from the
caretaker bring it to me in San benganza
and maybe I'll spare your girl's life
gotta get the contract from Carter Slade
where's the contract I can't end this without it
he may have my soul but he doesn't have my spirit
I did it for the right reason then that
makes you dangerous get you unpredictable
best thing you can be right now right now damn
Sam Elliott he's so good he really elevates this
what what oh snap
oh this is cool I got one last ride left in me
oh my goodness you keeper
that's right
oh my God yes was that predictable because
I didn't I did not see that coming I did not
see that color a little bit when he took
it out of the shovel but oh that is sweet
hahaha
just like on fire stick to the Shadows
the end of the trail for me he just rode there
yeah I guess he just escorted him to the place I
guess all I can do now is hope he sees fit
to give me a second chance thank you kid
I'm gonna ride back normally punch
this horse okay I thought they were
gonna like I thought we're gonna
like get a Crazy Action Figure yeah
well that was easy one down that was really
that was remarkably easy peace thought he was
going to die and then he was like fire come
to me and it did stop you've changed she dies
ouch all right
light it on fire
yeah oh sweet cool
looks like you're out of time
oh they still got a gun this is the
contract of San veganza come to me
whoa
absorbing all the souls he's just gonna be a
vessel for all them how is this a good idea
I don't feel like you thought this through man
no we have to wait till all the bad Souls get in
him and then kill him right or are they all just
like out in the open now I mean he's trying to
take them all in yeah so if he gets them all and
then we kill him then I guess we kill them all
my name is
why why you because he's the Ghost Rider God damn
it I'm the only one who can walk in both worlds
a Ghost Rider run
oh is there Holy Water Somewhere all of your
world all of your souls will be mine
now oh hell yeah all right roll it
flame bullets yeah man
what is that
what is happening what is going on are
they leaving or going into the thing
whoa what is this how does it feel
to have all that evil inside of you
a thousand souls to burn oh yeah yes yes your
souls are stained by the blood of the innocent
dude you're hurting hard right now devil
that's clever
hahaha
that's hot congratulations Johnny it's time
I take back the power of the Ghost Rider
what let someone else carry
this curse you're free now no
no and I'm gonna use it against you I will
make you pay for this can't live in fear yeah
devil just can't take it away it's not
oh because he can possess the member
he's like give me possession of it sure
is what you always were meant to be got your
second chance go out there and make the best
of it save lives what about your career for her
for him uh all that money too oh yeah he's got
like millions of dollars he could probably do some
good and dispensing some of that around you know
Legends are a way of understanding things greater
than ourselves this is how Legends are born
all right all righty all righty written and
directed by Mark Stevens Stephen did the whole
thing well Tara what did you think brag what
did you think we'll wait for a postcard fun
I liked it I liked it too yeah I mean there's
like of course it's not like wow amazing acting
but you're right about uh Elliot wait what's his
name Sam Elliott yeah yeah Sam Elliott uh he does
really Elevate the film he's a fantastic actor
and um I loved seeing Nick Cage just do Nick
Cage things like when he takes that long pause
in the beginning in the interview and he's like
yeah I'm like oh my God that's such
a Nick Cage thing and he's like yeah
it's so like I just I love that I love how he
plays it like a boy yes like a kid the whole
time is it's kind of like a curious Lost Boy is
how you play the entire performance yeah I agree
but sometimes when I look at it I mean in this
performance I'm like but doesn't he do that a
lot yeah I mean but he but he doesn't he does have
like a newfound wonder you're right he plays kind
of like a crazy guy yeah like a crazy man right
but here he's he's just like a soft-spoken boy
who's thrown into these like wacky situations I
thought it was so much fun this is this is pretty
wild because um uh I I thought that like some
of it would come back to me as we're watching
it you know like like a Fantastic Four there
was like three scenes I remember when hold on
it's credit okay there were like three scenes
I remember when like oh okay this is coming
back to me at this this moment this moment and
none of it was coming back none of it yeah the
whole time I was like are you sure you saw it I'm
pretty sure yeah I'm pretty sure I saw I remember
because I remember a very specific comment on my
friend's girlfriend made when we were watching
it uh it was it was that shirtless scene so it's
always stood in my memory she was like oh gross
because it just like looked unnatural and that
for some reason that's always stuck in my Noggin
um but it did look unreal like it doesn't look
real right fit he looks does look fake it's like
wow all right in a cage because he looks like
older and they try making him look younger with
his like incredibly dyed hair his hair is so so
black so black it doesn't look real at all no
um but I really liked it a lot because you
know I enjoyed I enjoyed his Johnny I feel
like as the Multiverse is opening
up in the MCU it'd be so much fun
Nicholas cages I was like dude wouldn't it
be so cool if you got a cameo or if they did
another Ghostwriter like now like now where Nick
Cage is at now all I'm thinking is the movie The
unbearable weight of massive Talent was so
good and I'm thinking now as him how would
he play it now as an actor and if they made like
a new one because I really like this and there's
some like I feel like there's moments that yes
it could have been better and maybe better uh
more well-directed especially with like Ava's
character it was like what's going on there that
it could be better written so now what if they
like redid it yeah it's true I mean they want
there's always talks of them redoing Ghost Writer
really matter of fact Brian Gosling threw his name
in that and the ringer for saying he would love
to play Ghost Rider like and then would Ava come
back yeah is that why it pitches like I saw
the way Nicholas Cage was looking at her yeah
um because yeah I I think this movie it captures
a good like Supernatural cheesy goth horror action
Vibe it's like yeah it's fun and I and the thing
is I don't feel like it it's not aware of what it
is like that's the thing is like it's something
that you can kind of laugh with because it feels
self-aware it doesn't feel like it thinks it's
cooler than it is at least that's my version
Vision that's how I viewed it yeah I was watching
I was like this movie feels self-aware uh with its
music cues and a lot of its comedy and the way
a lot of it's directed like it feels intentional
and a lot of it's cheap fees so I was able to
watch it as like a b movie pulpy uh silly movie
that occasionally looked really cool yeah like
when he divorced from the the ghost back to him
in that one shot I'm like dang it looks so good
and I mean he does it multiple times but there's
one specific one where it's like it goes it's it's
awesome yeah um that a lot of the facts are really
really good like when they kill that guy and then
he turns into like black and then lava like on
the ground what yeah that was awesome there was
a time in the 2000s where they were doing like
these darker comic book movies like I saw reacted
to Constantine here which is very Supernatural
demonic horror they had Daredevil which I think is
the same guy who made the Daredevil if I I might
be mistaken about that but they had Daredevil
which really had that kind of like grungy flare
about it uh that emo uh but this this one was
yeah I mean it was it was really enjoyable I do
wish we got a cathartic payoff though with Sam
Elliott writing off with him yes like why did
they not get to fight together I don't understand
that they really set it up but apparently he was
very literal about one last ride I'm just going
to ride the horse he didn't even do a full ride he
was like I'll escort you down the block yeah like
what I really would oh man that would be so cool
if they just like redid it and Sam Elliott was
still in it and Ava's character was written better
and it would be kind of fun if like if they could
play up the horror like because some of those were
actually with the faces coming in I was like oh
that's spooky but what if they even played with
it even more and made it like actually a little
jump scary if they made it actually scary for the
reboot that would be cool that would be awesome
because it kind of had like a horror aesthetic
but not horror and tone yeah and I could have used
some of that actual demonic horror tone because
yeah I mean it's by no means like I give it like
a seven out of ten just because it self-awareness
but it was more it was really fun but yeah that
was clearly ways you could have made this movie
better with like the action could have been better
like I like the visuals of the action more than I
like the choreography of the action if that makes
sense like I thought the chains were cool the bike
was cool yeah when he goes off that building oh
that was awesome that was awesome that was really
sweet but yeah the action itself could have been
executed a little cooler yeah um I enjoyed Nicolas
Cage's performance but yeah the the Eva Mendes
she was just was a massive joke oh that was like
like what you said like why is she coming in and
apologizing he stood you number one he left you
when you're 18 and the pouring rain with two bags
in your hands it doesn't seem like he apologized
for that either let's see if there's nobody
sure didn't oh here we go let's let's get it
I guess not oh my gosh there's not okay maybe it's
in the second one okay because yeah uh we waited
we waited to see if there was a post credit scene
maybe Amazon cut it off uh but yeah that was fun
music was cool but yeah overall the Aesthetics
and production design were pretty rad sandwich
that was a rad sandwich at the time yeah me too
I want a t-shirt like somebody leave a link and
then I'll go through it tag me I don't know I
mean I can look for it myself I get it but like
and also the villains could have been better like
ultimately the four whatever the elemental people
were so not essential like they didn't need to be
here for fights you're so right because I meant to
mention that one guy with the long hair who was
like constantly drooling or seemed very quietly
his water what did you think about that he was
water for elements because he only he only became
water once in the beginning of the movie and my
memory just goes whoop yeah uh that guy didn't
say anything like nothing he just stood there
dripping well they needed the soul thingy and all
it required was the one main guy Hive so bad with
names do you remember his name the one who guy oh
oh Bernard part I don't remember his name son yeah
yeah the Bennett here Bentar like I'm gonna know I
forgot the guy was water and I saw it yeah uh but
yeah all he had to do was go to Johnny's store and
be like give me the souls like the other three
didn't do jack [__] right and the journey to
getting the souls all he had to do was go to him
and be like okay I see what his weakness is he's
uh he likes her right right just give me the souls
that was all he had to do this entire time I did
think it was clever though when he did kill him
like that was a clever because I thought he was
just gonna shoot him to death right so when he
did because they did set it up that he can't use
it on him and then oh yeah that's right he'd be
filming that was smart that was super smart and I
liked that he made the tornado with the chain to
kill the guy with wind yeah I like that one too
chain tornado was fun the old chain the water was
like very easy I think they could have done more
with that nothing to it there wasn't he just
was biking underwater I drowned for a minute
and then I kill you like no big deal uh I don't
know I thought the wind one was awesome to see
and then obviously the last one but the other
I don't even remember was there four uh there
was four of them in total yeah what happened to
this the first guy got a chain wrapped around him
and maybe if they kept it to like one villain
it would have been but then we wouldn't have
gotten the wind tornado thing true true I mean
we got some like cool visual sequences out of
it uh I did I mean did they did the cops know
that's Johnny Storm likes of the cops so that's
what they established is the cops now know
that that guy is Johnny Storm I don't know
yeah it's it seemed like oh right because yeah
because he was on the news right he was saying
haven't you watched the news yeah like that he
was on there and that's why they came with all
the guns because they are probably aware of his
like I mean but then his friend was like if this
gets out to the Press but I was like I thought
the cops put together that guy's Johnny Storm
on top of that too there's all those people in the
prison cell who yeah who who were like who have
witnessed were privy and then one of them was left
alive though the kid yeah to where he could say
that was Johnny Stewart right yeah
like all rooms lead Johnny storm here
huh I don't know what I mean because what do
you think should have happened with them knowing
I mean giant storms should be a fugitive now he
destroyed half of Texas right uh he he did he uh
he did a lot of like um felonies like he destroyed
buildings ran up his motorcycle on the building
it's gonna cost like millions of dollars like that
whole building is shot the cop cars alone yeah
like Johnny Storm's gonna be looking at a massive
lawsuit and see this the next movie should just be
him on the run him on the run while paying court
fees he's like this is what he has to be dealing
with my bills are on fire maybe he maybe he
because he's a good guy that the second movie will
open up and he'll be like all this money I won
from jumping six black [__] helicopters yeah I'm
now giving to the city for all of my damage and
also I'm gonna pay you in advance because there's
going to be more damage from me killing bad Souls
yeah did you like it more than Fantastic Four yes
I liked it more than wait oh my gosh so much more
fun yes I mean absolutely I I was thinking in
my head while I was watching it if they remade
this and it was written a little bit better uh
like especially For Ava character I and made it a
little bit scarier I'm like this could be like an
a A plus movie yeah like it would be so awesome
but it's like a big budget b movie yes which I
would give like I would give a beat I'm still in
like they they did their job and and I liked it I
liked it a lot um I'm just like oh there are some
parts that are like a little bit like I heard the
second one's very weird I've never I've never seen
it really I don't know I don't remember I don't
even remember what the trailer was like it's still
in a cage right yeah okay yeah good good good good
good good howdy howdy howdy what did you guys
think about it did you like Ghost Rider was it
a fun movie for you surprisingly not a lot to
say if John was here to find 40 minutes worth
of content oh really yeah really so like you're
digging on me no no no I'm digging on me digging
on you not John yeah I can't break down all the
horses for 40 minutes just can't go see I feel
like we've said what it needs to be said if we
should move on I feel like we've broken down yeah
alrighty guys well thank you so much for being
here but before we go we gotta end this with a
patron of the day shout out Brian Perry Brian
I wish you could be the Ghost Rider for the
real rejects how cool would it be if there were
negative comments that show up in our comment
boxes and then what do we do we summon our Ghost
Rider Brian Perry to go after all of them and just
slaughtered them say look in the eyes and see all
those negative comments you've left on everyone's
YouTube page and now they're all going to be
directed at you all that bile and vitriol that
vindictive nature thrusted into their souls Brian
Perry you are the guy I believe in you to haunt
you're the one who's Gonna Save Us you gotta get
it done man you gotta get the chain make it go on
fire and then just slice through the meanies
comments life through the comments and slice
through them and then go after their families
go the extra mile make the family see the bad
that they've also done and then that way it
doesn't continue down the line because Brian
you're a mean man you're cold you're a freaking
monster Brian here you go on there you're gonna
Slaughter these people then I want you to
time travel and then wow just to go after
before they were born make sure they weren't
even born but then they haven't done anything
bad yet so you can't really use that against
them if they haven't been I have a crits like a
split timeline so it'll be like one time flight or
they can see what happens there's a scenario here
on the the going back you know but if we
could have just stayed you could have just
stayed where you were where where you were
going with what you were saying but you went
John should have done the show he went over
there you know and I was like still here
thank you Brian I think I
think we made good material
out of this I think we did a good
job thank you for being here buddy